[Music]
today's eight on your side inflation
causing more americans to borrow money
from family and friends but that can be
an awkward conversation we asked an
expert how to make it a little easier
and what measures lenders can take to
get that money back
these days household budgets are coming
under strain as inflation prices surge
it's forcing a lot of people to look to
other options to meet their short-term
financial needs according to the census
bureau's latest household pulse survey
of finances some 25 million people
relied on loans from those closest to
them last month up from 19 million a
year prior why are so many more people
borrowing from family and friends
because some 45 million americans are
considered credit invisible these are
people that either have a credit score
that's been so damaged that their only
options are to go to payday lenders and
lenders that charge crazy raids there's
also a group primarily of young people
across the country who don't even have a
credit score yet but there's a better
way says cabin clawson he and his
partner formed pigeon loans 18 months
ago a tool to help friends and family
make that borrowing process more
structured i watched my parents have to
borrow from friends and family i've had
to borrow and lend with friends before
in my life and it's always been awkward
a piece of software that creates a
contract bookkeeping and payment
reminders all automated it costs the
lender nothing and the borrower a little
more than five bucks what if um
you know more like other countries where
people you know lend with each other all
the time in southeast asia and africa
and latin america what if we could start
to normalize that kind of behavior in
america and i think we're going to need
to because as income inequality is
taking off
i think more people are going to need
help from from their fellow neighbor
as a lender make sure your financial
house is in order before you agree to
lend any money then create a contract
and know there's always a risk you won't
get it back but if you do a documented
loan the chances of getting your money
back are always better